Top five Muslims, Kevin. I was like,
praying five times a day. I was going to
the mosque every day.
Then I had sex once and I was like, God
Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this
brother of ours is facing. Just 10
minutes ago he couldn't stand.
And alhamdulillah through your donations
to Waqf Forever, today not only is he
standing, but he has a smile on his
face. Jazakallah khair to each and every
one of you who dignified our brother,
our father from Gaza.
Donate to Waqf Forever and help change
lives today.
A new upcoming Bengali comedian in
America called Osama had to prove
himself to Kevin Hart. At what cost?
Well, there's a whole discussion about
him being a Muslim or not. He said that
his father has left Islam apparently and
whatever the matter. So, it's clear he's
he's not a Muslim himself. And this is
what happens, guys. Subhanallah, when
you leave your deen, Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala leaves you in humiliation. Now
he's here trying to please himself to
Kevin Hart, you know, because when you
don't have trust in Allah, you trust the
style and trust in the means that he
gives. So, look at the stuff that he
says and it is absolutely unbelievable.
Uh Subhanallah, losing your hair after
fear for a few words of comedy. And the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi us clearly,
"The one who guards what's between his
lips and what's between his legs,
I will promise him Jannah." Yes?
And let's listen to what this man had to
say and Subhanallah,
ask ourselves a question. Subhanallah,
that is it worth Imagine, yes? You end
up in hellfire. I'm not saying he is or
he's not, but for that matter, look at
the stuff that he says and see it how
disgusting and vile he is. Top five
Muslims, Kevin. I was like, praying five
times a day. I was going to the mosque
every day.
Then I had sex once and I was like, God
might NOT BE REAL.
WOW! [screaming]
SEX WAS THAT GOOD? I LOST EVERY MUSLIM
VALUE IN THE FOUR SECONDS I LASTED.
My friend, you become a kafir. Five-star
graded kafir. Whatever if he's a Muslim,
but
this this straight away takes out of the
fold of Islam, straight away. Cuz we
know the ayah in the Quran which we're
going to come to in a minute and go to
scholars' view on
what is defined as mockery. But just
imagine losing the akhirah
because you want to be a comedian and
you need to make your best joke. And
guess what? You look at Kevin Hart's
reaction.
His reaction says it all. He shows that
he's basically saying, "Wow, like you
know, it's it's it's it's it's not even
laughing. He's just like wow." You know,
you can see how much when you degrade
yourself. You think Kevin Hart's going
to be like, "Whoa, whoa, you're such
good Listen, you're not you're nothing
to him. And guess what?
He probably lose respect FOR YOU.
EVERY PUMP, A NEW MUSLIM value out the
window.
Pump one, I'm like, "I'm trying bacon.
I'm doing it."
PUMP TWO, I'M LIKE, "SAUDI ARABIA'S kind
of sus, right?"
Bro, as I'm coming, I'M LIKE, "TRANS
RIGHTS ARE HUMAN RIGHTS."
>> [laughter]
>> GROWING UP,
YOU SEE, GUYS, SUBHANALLAH, when you
don't have a
a a an anchor in your life, something
that establishes you, something that,
you know, you have a um
grounding on. This is what happens.
That's what Allah subhanallah says in
the Quran, "Have you seen the one who
has multiple masters compared to the one
who has one master?" His master is the
crowd, the opposite gender, the money,
the fame, Kevin Hart. He's serving these
masters. And he's trying to do this to,
you know, everyone is sitting and
looking at him like, "Oh, is he
laughing? Oh, yes, I've got my You know,
the creation is happy with me. Oh,
they're laughing at me. I'm doing so
well." At the cost of guess what? That
those very people who are listening to
you in that
When you die, they're going to forget
about you, bro. Osama who? Who's
[clears throat] Osama? You're going to
be standing in front of your Lord. And
your Lord's going to be asking you
questions, my friend. Okay, but again,
firstly, we don't even know if this guy
is a Muslim or not. Looks like he's not.
Here's a another clip of him.
Um let's see what he has to say about
him, his father leaving Islam.
My dad was a super Muslim guy, became
atheist, and then kind of left the whole
life.
>> Holy sh- Yeah. That's fascinating. Later
in life Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. Deep,
but then he was started like
>> Was it 9/11 that did it?
Hey guys, NOT ME, BUDDY.
>> [laughter]
>> I I was wearing a cowboy hat. WE
GOT TO STOP THESE MUSLIMS. [laughter]
IT WAS LIKE A IT WAS LIKE a Steve Martin
thing where like you got the special.
It's amazing. You're like, I'm good now.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. We I can't tell I
can't top this. Uh Islam can't top 9/11.
I'm going out on top. Good as it gets,
y'all. I'm walking away. No, my dad left
it, and then he's now he's like a troll
online. He'll like
on Facebook, he's like attacking Muslim
uncles.
>> Maher-style atheist, bro.
>> Bro, he'll like [laughter]
One One of his big moves, uh the Muslim
word for God is Allah, right? And the
Hindu word for God is Ishwar, right? So,
he'll say the Hindu word for God when
he's commenting on Muslims
as a slight little like
>> Oh, what even What Which one of your
little made-up sky gods?
Look at this little flipping little fat
Humpty Dumpty there on the left left is
He acts like he's got some kind of
points. Like, you know, which one of
your made-up gods do you believe in,
etc. So, you can clearly see guys
that Subhanallah, and the verse is very
clear. The verse in the Quran Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala says in Surah Taubah,
we'll just quickly go to it.
If you question them, they will
certainly say, "We were only talking
idly and joking around." Say, "Was it
Allah and his
revelations and his messengers that you
was ridiculing?" "Make no excuse. You
have lost faith after your belief. If we
pardon a group of you, we will punish
others for their wickedness." Okay. So,
this hypocrisy that's talking about. The
hypocrites, both men and women are like
are are all alike. They encourage what
is evil and forbid what is good, and
withhold what is in their hands. They
They neglected Allah, so he neglected
them. Surely the hypocrites are the
rebellious. Yes, and when we look up,
for example, Islamic Q&A,
it says
here, inshallah, as you can see, If you
Ibn Hazm, Imam Ibn Hazm,
al-Zahiri said, "It is proven by sound
text that anyone who mocks Allah, may he
exalted, or any of the angels or the
prophets, peace be upon them, or any
verse in the Quran, or any obligatory
duties of the religion after proof has
reached them, is a kafir." Sheikh
Sulaiman
al-Sheikh said, "Whoever mocks Allah,
his book, his messengers, and his
religion, and becomes a disbeliever,
even if he did not really intend to mock
that, according to scholarly consensus."
There you go, again, that's that's
someone who didn't intend. Yeah, plain
intention. Secondly,
al-Ghazali says, "What is meant by
mockery is ridiculing, belittling, and
pointing out faults and defects by way
of laughing at something, and and that
may be done by in word and deed, or by
pointing, gesturing." Okay, I should
have said, "Just imagine
sacrificing the hereafter for a few
pleasures of this dunya, what is it to
make other people laugh? Okay, and the
matter is clear. We ask Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to guide this person back to
his senses. Yes,
my friend, there's enough ample of
evidence that God exists, Allah exists,
that Islam is a true religion. We have
the all there, you can watch my videos,
many other people's videos, for that
matter. But, to come there, and let me
tell you something, anyone, and this is
a reminder for these guys that are
watching, whoever's watching this, if
you try to please the creation at the
cost of the creator, wallahi, the
creation will never be happy with you,
and the creator will not be happy with
you.
If you try to please the creator at the
cost of the creation, let me tell you
something, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
make the people love you, and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will love you, and
will love you. Okay, so, it's so
saddening that to see that people who
have inferiority complex, you can see
with the whole 9/11 you have done, etc.,
you can see the deep insecurity. And
this comes stems from what? Not studying
your religion, not looking into your
faith, not understanding and giving it
time. You give time to everything but
Allah. And then, when you do that, and
you get doubts and insecurities, etc.,
cuz you can't answer questions, and
then, subhanallah,
you turn up like this. And it's such a
disgusting, like, vile thing to say, you
know, of all jokes you can make. And you
can see Kevin Hart there. It doesn't
really look like oh well what an amazing
Let's be honest with you. It was such a
dead joke. Like I genuinely believe they
have effects of making people like, you
know, when on TV to make it look like
they're laughing. They're not. It's such
a dead joke. It's such a disgusting
joke. So, we ask Allah to guide you
before it's late. Imagine a statement
that you utter leads you to the
hellfire. A statement that you belittled
and said oh it's not that much. And the
Prophet told us about this. So, we ask
Allah to guide this guy and also Kevin
Hart uh to Islam. And this Kevin Hart he
doesn't know Islamic background uh for
that matter. So, may Allah protect us
and make us among those who guard our
tongue. And this goes to Muslims who
backbite others, slander others. Yes, um
and talk ill etc. make lies. May Allah
protect us off that brothers and
sisters. I thought I'd just bring this
to your attention and make dua for this
individual Osama and send this his video
to him.
We're not saying that you're going to
hellfire. We're not doing people to
hellfire. That's not what we do. But we
are warning you of a severe punishment
that if you do not change your ways that
you know, it's not looking good. Till
next time. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.